it's been three months since Joe and I  put the chief in prison three months  since Joe abandoned me my god you  couldn't even keep your partner around  how are you doing here your old friend  Hideki Jones was murdered I need your  help to find his killer  this murder perfectly replicates  Hughes's death from Full Metal Alchemist  Brotherhood that's the cave from grief  of the fireflies these aren't just  random murders these are the saddest  anime deaths of all time we ran to a  serial killer the next victim could be  anyone it can be the next person who  walks through that door hey Joe Oh Joe  did you order the Cyberman pillow  it's so comfy  [Music]  this is what anime does to people  - gets them killed  [Music]  one more question have you seen  Dragonball Evolution the live-action  American remake oh so much better to see  the emotion on a human actors face don't  you think  [Music]